Hatice Cengiz, welcome to
Scandinavia.
I should say that this is the first time you talk
about this in English in an interview.
I'm very grateful for that.
We'll try.
Thank you for having me.
Both you and Jamal were experts on the
Middle East region.
Yes.
So you didn't only have
a romantic relationship, you also had
an intellectual relationship, right?
Yes, of course.
He was a really, really, really
good voice for me to understand ...
I really liked Jamal before I met him, as a
writer, as a thinker, as a person.
So ...
But then you met him and things happened.
Yes.
Apart from your conversations ...
What is it
that you miss the most about Jamal?
His voice.
And of course I miss a lot of
things, but it's not easy to talk about everything here.
We talked in the morning every day and I miss
his face. He was a really cute person.
He was more than a husband, a lover and
boyfriend, he was like my my father and
my brother and my mother sometimes. He was my advisor and teacher and best friend.
And I loved him a lot.
So ...
And he was asking, when he visited Turkey, Istanbul,
asking about the best restaurants in Istanbul and
took me to eat the best meal and ...
Do you still have his voice present in your head?
Yes, of course.
His voice, you know ...
Everyone knows now that they killed Jamal, but
I think Jamal's voice is everywhere.
Like now.
In Skavlan show in Sweden.
My voice is Jamal's voice.
I try to keep the story alive.
It's kind of a horror
story, but it's about real people and
It really happened.
I know it's hard for
you to talk about.
You were supposed to marry.
Yes.
But before that, he had to go to the consulate.
To the Saudi consulate in Istanbul.
Because he needed some documents to be able to marry you.
He entered and he didn't come back.
What did he say to you before he went in?
He told me: «see you soon».
«Wait for me here, I'll see you soon.»
You thought it would go quite quite fast and
then you were standing there waiting for him ...
Yes.
When did you start to worry?
After two hours, I think.
No, after three hours maybe.
I didn't think that something would happen inside the consulate.
As a writer, as a Saudi
citizen, as a really really big journalist,
I didn't think about this.
I was trusting Jamal's opinion.
He was relaxed, so you were relaxed, in a way?
Yes, that's it.
And you know, it was really
important for Jamal and for me at the same time
that we had to get this paper, and we thought it would be worth it to wait there.
Did you ask the guards after,
I mean, did you talk to anyone?
As time passed?
I was really, really, really afraid. And then I called the consulate.
They said: «wait there, I'm coming».
One came from inside, a Saudi person.
And I told him that I'm Jamal's fiancée.
And he was shocked.
From his face, I understood
that something had happened.
And then I urgently
called my best friend
and I told her: «come here
very very quickly».
And then I called someone who is responsible at the government.
And then one-two-three other calls.
When did you realize that he probably
wasn't alive anymore?
You know, if you remember the 19th of October announcement ....
The Saudi announcement on the 19th of October.
They said that Jamal was killed inside the consulate.
I was expecting
something different because ...
I didn't believe it because ...
It's really stupid to kill Jamal inside the consulate.
It's not acceptable, it's not a normal thing.
So you kept kept the hope and the faith
that he was alive for days and weeks?
Because, you know, Jamal told me
often that «my country is really, really beautiful and
good and you will change your opinion of my country».
As you know, I'm a
researcher and I had some idea about
Saudi Arabia, but it wasn't all good.
And he was saying to me:
«I will change your opinion with time and you will
become a very professional writer about my country
because of me.
I will teach you a lot of things». And then
he was really
optimistic.
So I tried to remember these points.
So ...
«No, no, no, it's so huge, someone
killed Jamal inside to consulate?»
But five men have recently been
sentenced to death.
Yes.
For this crime in Saudi Arabia.
What are your thoughts on that?
You know, it's really like a
joke to me.
It's unacceptable, really.
Because we don't know any details about
this investigation.
They only told us about five men who were not named.
And why are they five?
Because more than ten people came to Turkey!
And we want real punishment.
Even for the ones who ordered it.
According to CIA and the UN,
it's also possible that the crown
prince himself has been involved in some way.
Although he denies this firmly.
What do you think?
As you know, a special rapporteur in the UN,
said that there's a very, very big ...
I forgot the word.
Possibility!
... possibility that some people from the high level were involved this crime.
So that's why are requesting an international
investigation to get justice for Jamal and the others.
The fact that many
countries, among them I think Norway and Sweden,
have done nothing, really, does that
disappoint you?
It's really, really disappointing.
As you know, it's a really big shame for all people
around the world, not only Swedish people.
And that's because they try to normalize
their relationship with Saudi Arabia.
What's the difference between Sweden and Saudi
Arabia in this case?
Tell me!
You tried to cover this crime.
What's the difference between them?
There's nothing.
I wonder, the day
that started as a normal day for
you and Jamal ...
It was quite a normal day, you were supposed to
go to the consulate to get this paper,
what were the plans for the day
afterwards?
The plan was ...
We had already bought some things for our flat, even a refrigerator and a washing machine.
I was waiting for this
stuff and I called them and asked about ...
If we could come today and change some things. And buy things to our house.
And then dinner with our friends.
It was a really full day for us.
So that was the plan?
Yes, that was the plan.
If you were able
to ask him a question now, what would that be?
I blamed myself a lot.
I was thinking ...
Why weren't we more careful?
You blamed yourself because ..?
Because why ...
I don't know why I blamed myself, but ...
You know, I had to say something.
I had to say something to myself.
Maybe ...
It's a very difficult question.
What would I ask Jamal?
Why, Jamal,
do you have such an optimistic
opinion of your country,
more than they deserve?
Because they killed you.
Can I ask one question?
Has anybody from Saudi Arabia approached you after
this?
No, no, no.
No one called me.
Why would they call me? About what? What would they say?
Sorry, or something like that?
A «sorry» would not be for me, it would be for everyone.
And we need punishment, not apologies.
Hatice, how do you see your life in five years?
I'll be doing something for Jamal.
To keep his name alive.
And his case, and his story.
And his values, our values.
So I think that's my first responsibility
as a woman also.
Hatice, thank you so much for being with us tonight.
Thank you. Thank you.